you go where the story leads you and in
this case
it had i didn't had no idea it was going
to have a dark
conclusion my idea about a good idea is
one that sticks around and sticks around
and sticks around
i think the the best writers are
voracious readers
who pick up the cadences and the feel
of narration and around the time that i
turned 17 or 18
the nail fell out of the wall because
there were so many rejection slips on it
so i got a bigger nail
i just look for ideas that i really
enjoy something that i really want to
live with for a while i like the story
about the people under the dome
[Music]
my brother and i were both readers and
at some point along the way
i decided that i wanted to be a writer
so i started to type up stories on an
old typewriter
that i had and uh
and i started to send them to magazines
and i pounded a
a nail into the wall and i'd get the
rejection slips
back and i would put them on that nail
and around the time that i turned 17 or
18
the nail fell out of the wall because
there were so many rejection slips on it
so i got a bigger nail
and if there's any any secret that i
know to success it's uh if you don't
succeed get a bigger nail
yes yes there is something i want to ask
you all right
how the [ __ ] do you write so many books
so fast
i think oh i've had a really good
six months i've written three chapters
and you've you've finished
three books in that time here's the
thing okay
there are there are books and there are
books um
the way that that the way that i work uh
i try to get out there and i try to get
six pages a day
so with a book like end of watch and i
work
when i'm working i work every day uh
three
four hours and i try to get those six
pages and i try to get them fairly clean
so if the manuscript is let's say
360 pages long that's basically two
months work it's concentrated but it's a
fairly
but that's assuming that it goes well
and you do hit six pages a day
i usually do you don't ever have a day
where you sit down there and
it's like constipation and you write a
sentence and
you hate the sentence and okay you you
check your email and
you wonder if you had any talent after
all and
maybe you should have been a plumber
don't you have days like that
no i mean there's real life you know i
can be working away and uh
something comes up and you have to
basically get up and you have to go to
see the doctor or you have to take
somebody care package or you have to go
to the post office because
whatever but mostly i try to get the six
pages in
although entropy tries to intervene you
go where the story leads you
and in this case it had i didn't had no
idea
it was going to have a dark conclusion
you know you were mentioning
before we got going salem's lot and uh
when i started that story i thought to
myself
well this will be the opposite of
dracula where the good guys win and this
in this book the good guys are going to
lose and everybody's going to become a
vampire at the end of the book
and that didn't happen because you go
where the book leads you and this one
just
led me into a very dark place i didn't
even want to go there i want
people to find it out for themselves
but in any case john irving when he was
talking to a bunch of would-be writers
one time said
that the first thing he does with a book
is right the last line of that book
and i heard that and i just went you
know
like that because to me that's
kind of like spoiling the fun i like to
start
with a little bit of an idea you know
they come from different places
sometimes they stick around and you want
to do something sometimes they don't
but the idea is to start with something
and just
start to go with it you know and uh
that's the joy of finding things out of
having characters that just sort of
walk on and become a big part of the
story i
i feel like you have to follow the
characters and you have to follow the
story where it leads and
the last thing that i want to do is to
spoil a book with plot
so you know i think i think the plot
that plot is the last resort of bad
writers is a rule
i'm a lot more interested in character
and situation and you'll follow it where
it goes and
so anyway i had no idea that tad was
gonna die
and i had no idea that uh danny and his
mother were gonna live but i was really
glad
when they did people will say do you
keep a notebook
and the answer is i think a writer's
notebook is the best way in the world to
immortalize bad ideas
uh my idea about a good idea is one that
sticks around and sticks around and
sticks around it's like
to me it's like if you were to put
breadcrumbs in a strainer and shake it
which is what the passage of time is for
me it's like
shaking a strainer all this stuff that's
not very big and not very important just
kind of
dissolves and falls out but the good
stuff stays
you know the big pieces stay i had the
idea for under the dome
when i was teaching high school back in
1973 and it was just too big for me
and i was too young for it and i wrote
about
25 26 pages and
put it away there's a scene at the
beginning of this book where this
woodchuck gets cut in half when this
dome comes down over this town
i had written that part when i was in uh
in my early 20s and just sort of
recreated it from memory
when i when i wrote the book so the good
stuff stays
so does that does that mean that writing
can be um
taught can be learned
it can be learned but i'm not sure it
can be taught it's a
self-taught kind of thing i think the
the best writers are
voracious readers who pick up
the cadences and the feel of narration
through a number of different books and
you begin by
maybe copying the style of writers that
really knocked you out
uh i mean as a teenager i read a lot of
h.b
lovecraft so i wrote like hp lovecraft
and in my 20s i read a lot of
ross mcdonald and raymond chandler so i
wrote like those guys
but little my little you develop your
own style
i have a routine because i think that
writing is self-hypnosis
and you fall into a uh a kind of a
trance if you do the same
passes over and over so
i'll get up uh have some breakfast with
my wife
uh watch cnn and then i'll make my pot
of tea
and sit down and write for about three
and a half hours i started with short
stories
when i was 18 sold my first one when i
was about 20
and produced pretty much nothing but
well i wrote a couple of novels but they
were not accepted and a lot of them were
so
bad that i didn't even bother to revise
them
but the short stories were making money
and i got very comfortable with that
format and i've never wanted to leave it
completely behind you hear some people
who write who write short stories talk
about the fact that in their mind you're
they're they have these massive novels
written about these characters but
really what you see on the page
is just a sliver of a story that's in
their brain that they could tell they
could write a novel about it in most
cases
yeah what what it is true and what
happens to me a lot of times
is i will start out saying this would be
a terrific
short story idea and it balloons and
becomes a novel
misery started as a short story and
gerald's game started as a short story
those were things that i thought would
be
small and grew to a size where they
would be
a novel for a long time i felt like
movies were a lesser medium because it's
like skating
it's all on the surface
every now and then some movie will be
reduced to doing a voiceover you know
where this character is talking and i
could just kind of get the interior life
yeah and i just kind of go no no no
you've clearly mistaken this medium for
something that it's not
but i came to realize that films have a
language of their own and you have to
learn that language
and it isn't enough to say well i've
watched movies my whole life you have to
write a couple
i started i think i was probably
i'd been writing novels full time for
about a year and a half and i thought to
myself
i want to learn how to write movies i
want to try it anyway so i got a book
that was about writing screenplays and i
read it but at the end it had a sample
screenplay from the twilight zone
that showed me what the form was and
that was something real that i could
that i could so i took the ray bradbury
book
something wicked this way comes and i
wrote a screenplay
and i learned what i was doing it wasn't
for anybody but me
and then a little while later i wrote a
book called the shining
and it was my third book and i got
contractual rights to write the first
draft
screenplay for that and i did do that
and i found out later that
stanley kubrick who had got the rights
through warner brothers
had already determined that he and a
lady named diane johnson
were going to do the screenplay for the
shining
so they basically my screenplay went in
and they said no this won't do and then
they went on to what they really wanted
to do
which was fine i wasn't angry or upset
you're not after a while you get
thousands of rejection slips before you
break through you kind of get used to
that and it's just part of the game
but the thing is you learn you learn
little by little so
release books differently now than used
to in that like do you have a different
definition of what
a successful book is or where on the eve
of a book's release do you
pay a special kind of attention to how
it will be received or how it's being
reviewed
i think that if you spend too much time
worrying about what the audience is
going to like
that they're not going to like anything
that you do i just look for ideas that i
really enjoy
something that i really want to live
with for a while i like the story about
the people under the dome
and i get into it most of the time
and then i just have a ball i never
finished a book and felt like i'm glad
that's done
i usually finish a book and say geez i
don't want to say goodbye to these
people
and if the people who read it feel the
same way then
then i'm really happy look you know a
lot of these interviews the question
that
uh that's the worst is people will say
where do you get your ideas
i don't know where i get them you know
and if i did man would i tell you
i mean jesus they've been good to me
all i know is that i sit down and i turn
on the machine and there's always that
first
10 minutes that's like smelling a dead
fish or walking into a monkey house
and then something will click a little
tiny bit and that leads to something
else
and it's like
until it's going faster and faster and
then you hit this kind of uh escape
velocity you're gone
the world the normal mundane
sort of stupid world where you got to do
the breakfast dishes and you got to make
the beds
you know and you got to worry about
getting the kid to the dentist all
that's gone
but there's a place where you have to
walk away from it because it's so
kind of addictive that otherwise you
might just sit there and skip meals and
just being lost in that world and you
wouldn't want to do that because that's
sort of the way crazy people are
institutions you know what i'm saying
[Music]
you